et il reste encore des places pour le
spectacle de ce soir c'est à 20h30 au
zénith c'est une profession sinistrée
qui tient actuellement son salon à la
porte de versailles les cafetiers sont
en difficulté 6000 baroux bistrot mai de
chaque année la clé sous la porte à
paris mais le café de quartier évolue
aussi avec son temps l'avenir c'est
peut-être le cybercafé où l'on peut se
brancher sur internet 25 cybercafés ont
été créée à paris en moins d'un an
reportage anne gauthier il de wulf
latéral français libre service géré le
fait de pouvoir venir s installer et
utiliser internet à plus de l'avoir chez
soi et d'en être plus ou moins scav le
cybercafé une formule rentable le mode
d'emploi un design genre futuriste et
des consoles pour se connecter avec le
monde entier un service supplémentaire
consommer sans modération par les
passionnés d'informatique et les
industries du libre car je viens parce
que c'est utile c'est un endroit où je
peux montrer des choses à des gens parce
qu'on a des choses pratiques faire
ensemble et on le fait ici parce que ça
propose c'est comme une cabine publique
j'ai d'abord un café donc pas c'est
rentable à ce titre sur le même base que
les autres cafés italiens par exemple et
internet apporte en plus un thème au
café donc fait venir une population qui
a envie de découvrir a envie de se
mesurer
sur le réseau et donc c'est un plus on
fait par rapport aux autres cafés à 30
francs la demi-heure et 50 francs
l'heure l'intérêt ici est d'utiliser ou
de s'initier à internet à moindre coût
tout en s'amusant
c'est plus sympa dans un café on est
plus cher on se retrouve aujourd'hui
d'accompagner mon fils
oui j'ai trouvé ça intéressant parce que
sinon on va pas au café ensemble juste
pour boire on y va très rarement vous
allez lui offrir une consommation là oui
oui
aujourd'hui il existe 25 à fait comme
celui ci à paris et l'essor est très
rapide chaque mois de nouveaux cyber
café secret dans la capitale tchèque